une première médicale à lyon où le petit
david 16 mois va enfin pouvoir quitter
l'hôpital
il est le premier enfant avoir subi une
greffe
avant même sa naissance il avait reçu
des cellules de foie in utero david
vient de passer 16 mois dans une bulle
stérile
reportage fr3 lyon vide est sorti de sa
vue il ya quelques jours il était âgé de
16 mois pendant un an il a été protégé
dans ce service d'hôpital de grosses à
lyon contre les risques d'infection
bien avant sa naissance il était atteint
d'un déficit immunitaire très sévère il
n'y avait que deux solutions ou
l'avortement thérapeutique où une greffe
in utero c'est le graphe 81 alors que
david n'était encore qu'un foetus de 28
semaines
psychologiquement vous imaginez comme
c'est pénible pour une femme de se dire
qu'elle a un enfant malade et qu'elle a
qu'une solution soit de le faire mourir
dans son ventre soit de le laisser
naître mais de ne rien faire en
attendant la naissance et donc avoir une
fin de grossesse sans sans traitement
alors que l'un d'eux savoir que le
traitement a déjà entrepris et surtout
surtout que le traitement a beaucoup
beaucoup plus de chances de réussite
lorsqu'il est effectué pendant la vie
foetale alors là ça change tout à fait
les choses et bien sûr pour les parents
comme aux équipes soignantes c'est très
encourageant et la tante a duré 16 mois
et pendant six mois on a réinjecté à
l'enfant plusieurs fois des signes pital
la seule question qui se pose
aujourd'hui est de savoir si cette
greffe est réussi cet espoir est certain
je crois qu'on a apporté à cette famille
énormément en faisant cette technique
mais je crois qu'il est encore un petit
peu tôt probablement pour être très
affirmatif sur l'extension que cela
pourrait avoir
il faut avoir non seulement le résultat
fonctionnel et c'est ce pylône est en
train d'observer ses sept enfants
mais si vous avoir d'autres types de
preuves que la greffe a réellement pris
un succès pour cette première greffe in
utero est sans doute une autre
alternative à l'avortement thérapeutique